obviously I know what you're doing
you're churning butter and taste it and
tasting it to make sure it see if it
needs more salt so you're turning it huh
and then also it better even if you
don't proclaim yourself as a STONER and
you smoke a lot of weed you're still a
STONER in denial yeah that's probably
the only criteria for being a STONER is
smoking the pot I think if there was
some kind of marijuana that allowed me
to like enjoy life but still like
remember where I put my keys I would be
that cuz that seems like the best of
both worlds be like neuroses osmosis
whoa that's great there Rosie saw so
it's kind of what I do on this side
think of weeds you just make that up
yeah very good
Oh got it okay so you are basically an
old-timey shaman old-timey
yeah and somebody's come in with weird
heart palpitations and then this thing
this was the really intelligent you were
doing with this so you're giving him the
old CPR and then what you're doing here
is an old prayer where you take two
fingers and you put them near your lips
and then you do circles like the old
prayer and then the person obviously if
the impression went on would get up
thank you
pay you in shells and leave yeah pretty
much
this is amazing I know I actually
thought I wouldn't get these all right
so now we are going to test each other's
knowledge of pot paraphernalia so that
looks like the leg of a deer bleached
and on its side is that right it's
actually a joint you sanjohnno joint
okay so it's the joint of a deer Oh
obviously this is like a colander like
syrup so if you're cooking pasta you
would strain it in that device reckon uh
Frankie okay yeah yeah now it makes
sense this is like Austin Powers like
pulling out the penis pump it's like if
you know what this is then you are
really really right it's incriminating
Semyon vaporizer tourists vicarage I am
dude we have the same dreams enfin yeah
well I mean conceptually speaking I
think that we're on the same page I
think you might be surprised this is the
only thing I know how to draw it's the
Phoenix Suns logo from the early 90s it
doesn't reflect the experience of being
high but I can't draw anything else yeah
right these sort of like ambiguous
experience of being happy and within a
natural environment oh it's great is it
also an exploding volcano - correct
that's me oh that's a no no thank you
yeah yeah that's great so how should we
present it again
Merson yeah so I draw the 1983 Phoenix
Suns logo um I think it's the only thing
I know how to draw I went for like a way
and way more like literal specific
interpretation that's great I for some
reason and call Jessie Jessup sometimes
sure better than just down and so I'm
just like really wanting to promote the
movie cuz that's what it's called and
he's in it sometimes his name is Jessup
and not Jessie and he gets super high in
the movie that's so sweet can I keep
this yeah
you can also have I mean I guess you
probably want my Phoenix Suns logo yeah
you can have it
you're folding it cool it's respectful
while they keep it close I want to put
another pocket okay great